i mean he can guard multiple positions
he's a multi-faceted player offensively
as well so we're truly excited to have
him
there's something you said recently
regarding russell westbrook and that
you watched the lakers last year you
have a game plan for how to utilize it
expand
well it just you know in today's game
russ is known for you know
his his
just
huge competitive spirit
and you know
the velocity in which he gets up and
down the floor pushing the ball the
thing i said
you just have to diversify that you know
not only will he be leading the charge
pushing a break but screening and
rolling defending like i have a film put
together of him just
being a pit bull on defense and pick and
rolls against dhos you know chasing guys
off pin downs you know guarding
screeners guarding the post and that's
where it's going to start not only for
us but everybody a.d brian we got to get
back to playing defense um i think they
were either first or second in defense
the year they won the championship in
2020 so that's where it starts that's
where you're gonna make your biggest
change and your biggest improvement as
far as from an impact standpoint but
russ in my opinion man he's in great
shape he's durable uh and in this system
this four out one in system
he's gonna have a chance to screen and
roll and make plays in the half row he's
gonna have a chance to run on the break
slash get layups he's gonna have a
chance to sprint out to the corner
flatten the defense get corner threes as
well as the things that he already does
well in terms of getting the ball and
pushing the pace and pushing the tempo
so i'm excited as hell to have russell
westbrook on our team and we know health
plays a big part darvin and absolutely
and a.d when he's healthy one of the
best we've seen
well when you look at him and he's
inside he's outside and obviously he can
control the game defensively what have
you talked to ada what you want to see
for him
with the journey under you as a coach i
mean just being healthy said it being
available um and we have to do our job
as a coaching staff
to uh you know have a solid plan
rotation wise
minutes per game um how we're managing
this body with our strength conditioning
staff
but just being available whenever he's
available
he's a problem top five player in our
league hands down and he's the factor if
he's not healthy none of this other
stuff is going to work make no mistake
about it you know brown is going to be
brian brown is going to be great
russell's going to be rushed but aed
is that piece that centerpiece on this
table that we have to have available in
order to do what we need to do
thanks anthony davis
darmian we appreciate you stopping by
congrats again my friend thank you